who is the New Black Panther fans think
the newest trailer for wakanda forever
has revealed the answer tickets for
black panther are kinda forever are
officially on sale and a typical Marvel
fashion the studio released a brand new
trailer to celebrate this latest
official look at the film Dives deeper
into the conflicts between wakanda and
talukan following the death of King
t'challa it's still up in the air how
exactly wakanda forever writes off
Bozeman's titular hero but based on the
currently available footage it's now
clear that t'challa has passed away in
the MCU in this newest trailer wakanda
is mourning as King's death which leaves
a country vulnerable to an invasion
Neymar and his people's full strength is
then on display as they attack wakanda
and even flood one of its cities viewers
also get close looks at Namor shuri
mamonda and Riri Williams finally the
trailer's last shot gives fans what
they've all been waiting for a look at
the New Black Panther show them
following the tragic death of Chadwick
Boseman in 2020 theories took over the
internet as to who would take up the
Black Panther mantle next some fans
believed Marvel Studios should have
recast a role to maintain t'challa's
presence in the MCU but Marvel Studios
head Kevin feige told Empire that it was
too soon for such a change others
thought giving the role to an
established character was the way to go
with shuri Nakia andu Baku being the
most popular choices it's now apparent
that Marvel Studios has chosen the New
Black Panther and many fans think
they're sure who it is Leticia writes
shuri plenty of fans are loving this
apparent Revelation Twitter exploded
with fans sharing their assignments with
plenty of users loving pretty much every
aspect of the trailer Neymar's reveal
Riri Williams mark one einhardt suit and
the return of beloved characters from
the first film all seem to be highlights
but the New Black Panther reveal is a
clear standout among fans online the
question of whether shuri or Nakia might
be wearing it lots of Twitter users came
to the conclusion shuri is darling the
costume in the trailer and fans are
excited to see her as the New Black
Panther one user wrote so that confirms
it it's shuri I'm not mad they could
have recasted but I'm not mad another
said yeah that's 100 sure he behind that
mask and another excitedly tweeted shuri
is about to devour as the next Black
Panther you are teaching me what do you
know
more than you it's worth noting however
that viewers don't actually see shuri in
the Black Panther costume in the new
trailer the person in the suit who
definitely looks to be a woman is fully
masked but it's heavily implied that
this new incarnation of the hero is a
younger sister of t'challa though some
viewers did point out it could be Nakia
in the costume surely in the care of
long been two rumored options to become
the next version of the iconic hero the
latest trailer as well as the film's
newly unveiled poster strongly suggests
that we'll see Leticia right in the role
then again Marvel is known for faking
out fans and promotional materials a
Reddit thread argues that shuri's
Presence at the center of the new
Poster's character lineup acts as
confirmation that she's the franchises
new titular hero a commenter and a
similar thread even pointed out that
markings on the New Black Panther suits
match Sherry's signature face paint so
users online excited about the prospect
of shuri becoming black panther based on
the latest trailer seemed to have plenty
of evidence supporting their assumption
fans can find out for sure whether or
not shuri is taking her brother the
t'challa's place when Black Panther
wakanda forever its theaters on November
11th